by the going back when you said you you
your dad was in the army for 22 years or
24 years when when he was in you said
most of the time in asia what part of
asia was it okinawa was it korea was it
cam casey
so we lived in seoul korea we lived in
uh beijing china uh we did some time in
japan and uh
and that that was pretty much it so
and i know
how was china back then when when you
were i mean even as a kid how old were
you when you were in china i was in uh
kindergarten in first grade uh but i
remember it pretty vividly um you know
it was uh it was a lot different back
then than it is now i'm just seeing it
on the tv now like there's
no vehicles uh everybody was riding
bicycles
it was interesting you know we had uh
of course you know my dad working there
at the embassy
you know we had um
chinese nannies because my mom taught
english while she was there but they
were all spies uh so we pretty much had
spies
uh that were trying to gather
information on us get out of here
yeah uh your nanny was a spy how'd you
guys figure out that your nanny was a
spy oh she told my parents uh because
she was
she was getting uh a lot of heat from
the government because she there was
nothing to collect uh she was watching
myself my little brother so i think they
were on top of her telling her you know
like hey we need some information and
then uh
i think my parents threw a party at one
point you know and had a lot of guests
over uh we lived in an apartment and uh
that's you know they said that the
nannies were super excited and thanking
them because then they could actually
you know report something back um so it
was it was pretty interesting you know
obviously i didn't know a lot of that
was going on but now you know hearing
the stories now for my parents
it's uh what was your job what was your
dad's mos
um
he uh mp i don't he was uh military
police
yeah got it he was an mp interesting mp
in uh in uh
china base oh
that i mean he he spoke five different
languages so it was uh he was you know
obviously the
army used him in the best ways they
could he spoke five different languages
how how did he speak five languages
he's
he's a
remarkable human being
impressive man that's
and your dad is a caucasian american
yeah irish
speaks five language what were those
five languages
um see the
i think it's two or three dialects of uh
you know chinese so it's like cantonese
uh something i and i'll mess it up but
also korean uh german german i think he
speaks some french
and and did he go from mp did he move up
higher did he end up doing other other
things as well or was it just 22 years
24 years and he retired
24 i mean he didn't want to retire he uh
you know he ended up
while we were in korea he went to desert
storm uh when that was going on came
back and then i think
at the time of clinton was president and
they were doing a lot of uh budget cuts
in the military and he was just told
like your time's up uh it was
it was pretty crushing to him because he
loved the army but you know it was what
it was i remember they were doing that
when we're in the army they'd come up to
you and they say listen here's what
we're doing we're giving a bonus for you
to leave the army and not stay in and
the you know budget cuts when it happens
some of the guys that are around longer
they're the ones typically that are the
first to go and they go and ask them to
go maybe they'll give a bonus
uh to ask them to leave so if you like
this sort of short clip from an
interview i did click over here to watch
the entire interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye
[Music]